what's up Samuel leaves here and I hope
you're having a fabulous weekend this is
the first time I've ever done a video on
a Sunday and from now on I'm gonna be
doing a video not only every Sunday but
every single day so mentoring Monday T V
Tuesday winners on a Wednesday
thoughtful Thursday
financially free by Friday podcasts a
day and Q&A Sunday so what does that
mean that means that all your questions
that you post in the comments I actually
read we're gonna kick spell at this
right now is I'd love you if you've got
any niggling property questions comment
them below on this video and I'm gonna
be choosing the best few questions you
know maybe give me some context about
your background about your story and the
better your question the better my
answers will be able to be and then I'm
gonna take the take a few of them and
that's all I coming up Kuban a Sunday so
get posting below and I look forward to
reading and doing a video response super
soon thanks so much peace out